hello you're watching entertainment week
with me isabel webster coming up on
today's show the x-men are back again
hugh jackman will explain how wolverine
nearly ended up with a perm
josh hartnett joins us to talk monsters
and murders and why he fancies being the
first american james bond and we have a
legend of the west end here in the
studio the first lady of musical theatre
elaine page will be telling us about her
new tv show and her farewell tour
first let's catch up on the week's
entertainment news
we learned jay-z may have more than 99
problems after footage from a hotel lift
was leaked online showing his
sister-in-law solange making her
feelings known with a clutch bag but all
was forgiven as big sister beyonce
posted pics of the pair on instagram the
trio say they're moving forward as a
united family
there have been calls for gary barlow to
give his obe back for good after he and
his take that band mates put money in a
tax avoidance scheme
carolina hearns revealed she's fighting
lung cancer she's had the disease before
in her bladder and eye
over on the french riviera the stars
have been out for the cannes film
festival prince william hung out with
another kate and a few more famous faces
at a charity dinner
and a beautiful bearded lady stole our
hearts at eurovision could a duet with
gaga be next
boy george had tweeted i love it
and lady gaga had tweeted conchita wurst
you complete me
well elaine it is wonderful to have you
with us we're gonna be talking about
your brand new show in just a moment but
first of all we're going to talk about a
few of those big stories of the week as
we check out what's been trending online
sophie haywood is with us and really we
just have to start with the jay-z and
solange footage that was leaked from
that list that everybody i know has
watched about 10 times yeah it's
extraordinary
i mean
so many things to talk about you didn't
see it
but you just stick with it
so what we're looking at here is
beyonce's sister attacking her
brother-in-law jay-z oh i say
violent
yep and it's kind of interesting
watching the interplay between all the
characters isn't it because actually
jay-z doesn't retaliate and believe it
or not beyonce is standing just there
and there's very little to to stop funny
it makes you wonder if beyonce is used
to seeing this because she's not
massively surprised or at the same time
it could be that her and jay are so much
more famous than solange they are so
used to the public eye that they know
even in a lift there's going to be a
camera there's a security guard who
might sell a story you know they know
they just have to be composed at all
times it's interesting because i've
actually met solange in los angeles we
had a night out together some years ago
and she was the sweetest person i was
pregnant at the time and i remember her
rubbing my tummy with a gentle rub and
then saying let me show you my stretch
marks because she has a nine-year-old
son so something's provoked
now how are we going to find out what
that's the thing the whole world wants
to know
i fear we may never we have to talk
about batman as well though why is
everybody talking about ben affleck
people were so horrified when ben
affleck got the gig of playing batman
and i didn't understand that he seemed
quite a sort of brooding manly actor to
me i didn't see it to be such a
a bad fit but i think the thing is
you're dealing here with comic book
nerds who are not going to be happy with
anything but you can't make it anyway
i mean it hardly matters who's playing
it yeah absolutely and sophie we have to
talk about michael jackson as well this
new video has been released featuring of
course justin timberlake tell us all
about it well michael jackson has
released his second posthumous album
this week it's not even the first one
this one they've gone through through
some old release material and they've
got timberland the producer to do it so
it's actually quite a lot better there's
some good songs i don't think we're
missing any huge hits from him but it's
it's good that's one to check out if you
haven't already sophie haywood thank you
ever so much
and the final story there of course the
opening of the cannes film festival
let's go to steve hargrave who is there
for us steve loads of huge names
descending on the mediterranean who's
hitting the headlines
well the biggest one i guess we should
talk about it really although she
probably doesn't want to be reminded was
the opening night film grace of monaco
nicole kidman of course starring as
grace kelly who's a member of the royal
family just down the coast in monaco the
monaco family themselves have disowned
this film and it has to be said although
nicole put in a great effort on the red
carpet coming down smiling and posing
there's a big red carpet this one the
reviews of course were not fair the
following morning i read a couple of
quotes out from some of the reviews
nicole if you're listening just you know
cover your ears for a second uh stiff
stagey thunderingly earnest cardboard
size-splittingly funny although it's not
meant to be a comedy and so wooden it's
a fire risk said the guardians so nicole
won't be happy with those reviews but it
is kind of more about being seen out
here in cannes and what we've seen since
nicole is all of the stars starting to
flood in big hollywood stars matthew
mcconaughey were spotted and also out on
the carpet at these big parties the
ladies putting in a stellar performances
in their frocks lots of british interest
though on the film side of thing this
year isn't that steve yeah it's quite
funny as well because just behind me at
the moment mike lee is doing interviews
just over there for his film mr turner
now if we talk about nicole's film being
slated mr turner is a movie that after
he walked down the red carpet with his
cast including timothy spall as the the
title character he got some fantastic
reviews five stars pretty much across
the board from the british press and
also a lot of interest he's a bit of a
canned darling mike lee and i spoke to
him earlier and he says he does want to
win the palm door which he's up against
and interestingly he's going up against
ken loach he's got a film here called
jimmy's hall which is a 1930s irish
political activist film again ken loach
has previous form has won before and
those two are seen as very very strong
competitors to pick up the palm door
come the end of the week so strong
buddhist interest on the directing front
a lot of other british stars in town and
a lot of british journalists it has to
be said trying to get to the free
alcohol at the parties on the beach and
lots of a-listers wanting to come and
party as well other big names expected
over the course of the next week
yeah and i know you're very excited
about this because uh the ryans are in
town ryan reynolds rocked up today
actually for the premiere and launch of
his big movie uh called the captive in
the film he sports a big beard he never
beard today but he was certainly trying
to appear a bit older some saying this
was meant to be the performance that
sort of got him back in in line with the
critics really after doing some slightly
less successful movies uh but it has to
be said again the reaction from the
canned crowd today not that favorable
for ryan reynolds ryan gosling the other
ryan i think you might have heard of him
he's got his directorial debut called
lost river that's interesting to us
because doctor who's matt smith pops up
in that as does christina hendricks from
mad men and then finally of course
robert pattinson he's here not just for
one film he's here for two films but as
i said before it's not really about who
wins that big award it's more about
being seen being photographed and having
the biggest dazzling smile on that red
carpet oh steve hargreave thank you so
much the tough gig you've got there but
i'm sure you'll find time to enjoy
yourself
now it's hard to imagine what musical
theater would have been like without my
next guest during her 50 years on the
stage she's played iconic parts in hit
shows like cats evita and sunset
boulevard now elaine paige is turning
her attention to television with a new
sky arts show let's take a
is look never left you
all through my wild days my birth
existence i kept my promise
don't keep your distance
so elaine we can get all sorts of things
from your brand new show including
performances from you yeah what else can
we expect well i'm singing the opening
and closing song
on the other six programs that are shown
on wednesday night at eight o'clock and
sky one at 6 30 on a saturday
i have other guests on on from musical
theatre um a creative person like dame
jillian lin tim rice andrew lloyd webber
trevor nunn and then peppered through
the conversation because there's sort of
like a chat show with musical
performances so it's for lovers of all
things musical theater
in your show biz friends who was your
favorite guest oh my goodness that's
terribly unfair because everybody is
unique and each performance and
conversation that i had was one very
different from another
maureen lipman was on one week and she
loves to tell a good tale and she's very
funny so that was a rather good program
but it's a it's a bit of a mix and of
course a plus the the guests that
perform and and that i interview uh each
week i have a young student from a drama
school
from
arts education or mount view and they
come on and we've worked together on a
song that they want to perform and it
gives them an opportunity to know what
it's like to be in a television studio
for their first ever outing as it were
so in a way you're getting involved in
people as they're sort of starting that
yeah because i know you've been
outspoken about being critical of these
sort of talent shows that thrust people
into the spotlight and they haven't
necessarily worked their way up the hard
way like you did so is this your way of
sort of trying to help people yes trying
to address the balance if you like for
for a drama students who take on a
three-year course you know and go and
work hard and study at a slower pace
that's the thing that i think i'm more
concerned with really and this gives
them the opportunity
they're third year students so they've
done almost their entire uh course and
it gives them an opportunity to know
what it's like to actually to to work in
a television studio and and to work on a
song and and and the storytelling
because that's what it's all about and
you've had your own radio show for 10
years now you have this tv show we're
going to see more of this kind of thing
because you're doing your farewell tour
this year yeah packing your bags and
saying no more well i'm not exactly
retiring that terrible world no not
indeed i i'm
i'm really just hanging up my touring
shoes really it's just the traveling
that has become a bit of a bind the new
album that's great fun because it's all
the warner tracks uh from about mid 80s
through to date and we've found some
extra tracks that we'd forgotten all
about in the archives so we've put those
on it for for fans and i've done a dance
track of be on your own from the musical
nine
so it's it's quite an eclectic mix of
songs and you're very adamant that
you're not planning to retire any time
soon a lot of people who are in musical
theatre say they never will they can't
it's in their blood is that how you feel
well it is really i mean it is a bit
like a drug you know it's something that
you've done all your life and i can't
imagine not doing it but of course
musical theater is very much i always
think
now a young person's game because it is
so demanding both physically and vocally
and and you've got to be really at the
the peak of your health and
you know you've got to be really fit to
do it and of course i like to enjoy a
little of real life as well now so um so
this is gonna afford me to be able to do
some one-off concerts keep recording
albums and hopefully uh to
you know keep my toes dipped into the
world of television well there's still
certainly a huge amount of appetite to
see it's been an absolute pleasure
talking to you we wish you all the best
with all the things you've got planned
for 2014 elaine page thank you very much
thank you now coming up in a few moments
josh hartnett will be here in the studio
to tell us why he's returning to tv
after 15 years with the new drama penny
dreadful and don't miss our film review
for all this week's big releases
now some of the scariest monsters in
literature are coming to our tv screens
next week the new drama penny dreadful
manages to combine vampires frankenstein
egyptian mummies and even dorian gray
makes an appearance in a moment we'll
talk to the show's gun-toting cowboy
josh hartnett but first let's see him in
action
so it's a job
this night work
yes
something of a criminal setup
would it matter not at all then why ask
joe's heading off to paris pretty soon
the job's tonight
is it a murder would it matter
one smile and i say yes
meet me at this address at 11 o'clock i
don't know london then ask a policeman
you have a name
oh it reels you in so it's set in
victorian britain how would you describe
the show well it's set in 1891
a lot of the characters from classic uh
english especially english literature
that have
horror bent to them are living in london
at the same time and treated as actual
people and going about their daily life
and my character is an american who
comes in at an inauspicious time and is
kind of brought along
to some very supernatural events with uh
with by eva green's character and and
how important were the other players in
it for you and enticing you into doing
this because it's got a lot of bond
connections hasn't it yeah well john
logan wrote skyfall as well so he
created this and wrote skyfall sam
obviously directed
skyfall um and uh and tim bing bond ava
being a bond girl there are a lot of
bond connections rory caner is in it as
well he's in he's in the sky fall as
well
um
i thought that maybe they were grooming
me to be the first american bond but i
doubt that's gonna be the case
i mean i wonder what enticed you to the
small screen again because we're used to
you from the big hollywood blockbusters
we haven't seen you for a few years this
is the first time you've been back on tv
since your debut when you were 18 years
old yeah it's been a long time since
i've done television the reason that i
wanted to do this was not so much it it
wasn't about the format it was about the
people involved like you said that list
of people was pretty impressive um
juan bayona also is not to be overlooked
he's the he's the man who directed the
first two episodes and he's a really
he's an incredibly talented director
so it's all about for me it's all about
the collaborators and
these days you go back and forth between
tv and film very easily much more easily
than it was for someone from tv to move
into film back when i i did it it's such
a gory gory series isn't it i mean
there's a lot of blood there's a lot of
guts how did you personally stomach that
well it's not it's not very hard on set
because it's obviously like you know
made of corn syrup
but uh but the
the the gore is i think a good way to
get audiences involved at the beginning
but i but really it's i mean you look at
the people who are involved it's not
it's not about the gore the blood and
the guts and the scares it's about the
characters and how they grow and how
they interact did it mean though that
there was a lot of time in makeup and a
lot of time doing sort of all the
sometimes yeah and how do you find that
do you enjoy that kind of creative side
to it or you prefer to just get it to do
the job well you know it's something
different no i i'm not so old and jaded
that i would you know get
uh that i wouldn't enjoy a new
experience
some of these things are new i've done
some things on this show that i've had
i haven't had a chance to do before um i
don't know if you saw it in that clip i
don't think you did but i get to gun
slinging in this show so i had to learn
how to spin guns and shoot accurately
from the hip and do you like that side
of the job which is quite a physical
because you've been described as a sort
of natural athlete and that's why a lot
of these leading roles come to you and i
wonder if that's a side to it that you
particularly enjoy doing your own stunts
for example and natural athlete
i'm paying you maybe
i uh yeah no i love the i love doing the
stunt stuff i love just i love learning
a new skill whether it's physical or or
if it's you know i mean i i don't i love
learning a new card trick you know i
mean if you have something that you have
to do for work that's so unusual like
that that's that's that's a bonus in
terms of your own career i know that you
were in talk certainly with superman
returns and there's there's rumors that
you you were lined up to be in
spider-man and these other big action
roles do you regret having not taken
those or followed that i don't have any
career regrets i've done i think some of
my best work in the last few years
um within very worthy films it's just
not
unless you're doing the few very big
blockbusters every year there's not the
kind of money in advertising that you
get for like a television show like this
we have in this show i think more
advertising than any film i've done
since black rock down and i've been in
some studio films that i've had less
advertising and i've been in a lot of
independent films that have had a lot
less advertising so it may seem to some
people in the public like i went away
but really i was just working with
i think really interesting were they
directors in independent film when you
did do those films pearl harbor black
walk down early twenties really hard to
handle that kind of fame in your early
twenties
what was it like being a hollywood star
that was thrust into into the spotlight
so young well it was like a lot of
things i don't really know i mean we
were
when we shot black hawk down i was 21
years old and
when we completed it not long after i
was living in new york and obviously it
was
september 2001
everything sort of changed
and i took
quite a few steps back after that moved
back to minnesota spent a lot of time
writing and
doing some doing charity work and and uh
and
just wasn't interested in playing i
guess what was expected of me in the
game in hollywood
uh but now
with a few more years under my belt it
feels
it feels i mean this is as good a job as
i could ever hope for i love working in
film and tv and i've had a great time on
this and hope to continue well josh we
wish you all the very best with this of
course so this is going to be on on
tuesday night on sky atlantic penny
dreadful so thank you very much for
talking to us about that thanks a lot
time now to see what's on at the cinema
this weekend in a moment we'll speak to
our film reporter joe but in the
meantime let's take a look at our first
pick godzilla
so joe 160 million dollar budget
reportedly is this just about special
effects um
a little bit yeah i mean i think that's
probably a fair point to say but it's
not in the just about special effects
and same way sort of avengers is and all
those transformers which is just sort of
rendered pixels beating seven bells out
of each other it has got a heart bill
suspends incredibly well in fact we
don't actually see godzilla until the
sort of the first hour sort of spielberg
and jaws-esque and the fact that we're
just waiting to see this monster and
when you've got that tease you're always
gonna have a big reveal and the reveal
has got to be worth it and when we do
see him and when we do seem sort of
reducing much of west coast america to
rubbles it's absolutely fantastic and
much of it is sort of told through the
human point of view as well sort of
shaky cam and through
tv news reports so it's grounded in
realism so you never sort of think this
is a computer character beating up
another computer character it's easily
the best disaster film i've seen in 15
years it's absolutely fantastic where it
kind of like falls a bit short when you
compare things like independence day and
titanic you know the great disaster
movies about the modern years out of ten
a strong seven well let's move on to the
two phases of january to me this seems
to be very much in the sort of vein of
the english patient
yeah it's uh evocative it's classy it's
really old school it's i mean it really
is a film noir sort of sort of like a
casablanca esque movie it's the kind of
films that they don't make anymore it's
a tightly woven and every line matters
there's never any sort of superfluous
and wasted dialogue in this film and and
and you just sit there and you enjoy it
and the three leads are absolutely
fantastic and it's it's old school
glamour and excellence let's take a look
at it
it's a young guy and a great shirt
staring at me
she's very pretty isn't she
what are you doing nathan i'm a tour
guide you're american you believe you
can ask him yourself he's going to show
us around the flea market sunday what do
you do for a living sir i look after
people's savings
hey won't you uh join us for dinner
so what do you think i wouldn't trust
him to mow my lawn
mr dunleavy
i think you can absolutely stunning
cinematography you kind of want to jump
into the screen don't you it sucks you
in it transports you back to 1960s
europe when sort of men walked about
abandoned ruins in linen suits and
everyone looked beautiful and
you traveled you know without sun
lounges and eating english fry ups it's
a beautiful film it takes you back to
that period in time and it's well worth
the watch well in stark contrast to that
let's preview what's coming out next
week the latest x-men movie latest x-men
movie this is when they sort of combine
the two cars so you've got the same
characters of michael fassbender james
mcavoy along with that ian mckellen and
sir patrick stewart it's gonna be
interesting to see where it goes from
here if this is
successful you can imagine they will
keep this cast together but also of
course you've got the spin standalone
movies hugh jackman who's the ever
present in the saga and when i spoke to
hugh jackman i took him back to that
time in london when he had his first
audition for the role of wolverine
i was in london doing oklahoma at the
royal national theatre and i ran from
the matinee it was a wednesday i ran
from the matinee into soho to do a test
and ran back and did the show i had a
perm in my hair i had a really bad
american accent i think i just did my
curly southern cowboy accent as
wolverine how the hell i ever got a call
back i have no idea so a slightly camp
permed wolverine what's your initial
take on this nothing camp about hurley
curling but uh no i was it it was a
miracle it was lauren schuldener
actually who was the producer of the
time who saw it i am forever grateful
she is
she saw something that i'm sure was not
there you go back to the 70s in this one
so really your initial audition with the
perm
you were ready for it yeah exactly i was
thinking of my time
exactly i should have done that
and even the leather chaps that i was
wearing straight from the audition he
seems like some kind of character who
fits into the 70s though he's like
totally he's got the facial hair chops
the big build buckles motorbikes scotch
i actually you know i kept dad living
throughout the thing like he's in the
70s and he goes back and he gets into a
car and the moment he turns it on i was
like yeah
it's almost like everything's about yeah
it's wolverine stopped in the 70s you
know the moment the 80s and wham and
rick astley came it was like he checked
out i can imagine you you go back in
time as well now every hollywood movie
where they go back in time you can't
upset the space time continuously even
though no one has ever time traveled so
how do we know that that's true we
studied it at school yeah
you must be something you do in
australia well i can tell you brian
singer takes it very seriously because
yes this is i he does now this is a
i think
probably the secret to his success was
he took mutation seriously uh he used to
show us articles and
and talk to us about why are we eric so
arrogant to think that we're fully
evolved we we talk about evolution but
who's to say humans have
fully evolved we don't use 80 of our
brains so maybe we're just at the
beginning so he used to sow that in all
the time and when it comes to time
travel
he's as ambitious to make this the best
time travel movie as he is to make it
the best superhero movie trust me
he's so personable isn't he and it
wasn't just a hugh jackman that we
managed to catch up with but also
michael fassbender to ask how he thought
the x-men franchise could continue
it's a business that we're part of and
obviously
the next film doesn't get made unless
the one before it makes money
that's no secret there
uh
is the marketplace saturated with
superhero films in general at the moment
some people would say yes but other
people would say well more people are
going to the cinema than ever
next time on entertainment week drew
barrymore and adam sandler are together
again they'll be telling us about
achieving a work-life balance and
whether a new perfume range could be on
the cards and nick frost's here in the
studio to give us a taste of 1960s
watford in his new comedy mr sloane